so some of you might be wondering why
I'm not wearing any makeup and some of
you probably can't even tell the
difference so either way it's because
I'm about to transform myself into my
Halloween costume let me know in the
comments below what you guys are going
to be for Halloween and uh have a happy
freaking
[Music]
Halloween oh my God I hope this comes
off I got to pull all this hair up cuz
this is going to get
messy oh my God I'm going to need a
hose to get this off of my
[Music]
face okay I think that's
enough I hope this is for your
face
okay we're almost
[Applause]
[Music]
done I'm The Annoying Orange I'm pretty
excited uh I uh I'm an orange I'm real
orange and I have a feeling this is not
going to come off of my
face
trick or treat you guys I am in the Call
of Duty Black Ops 2 liveaction
trailer